aber ich bin ein junge
hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zahlen neuen video
ritschel und titel eingeblendet und zwar
killer clowns versus clever bot wir ja
ich habe wieder so ein bisschen mit dem
clever wort geschrieben dann habe ich
mir einfach mal gedacht was hält der
clever wort eigentlich von killer klauen
uns das fragen wir denn heute und an
alle technikexperten unter euch hab ein
paar probleme mit meinem monitor als ich
werde am ende noch mal kurz sagen was
man genau das problem ist also bitte
bleib dran und helft mir
wir begrüßen den clever bot erster mit
hallo clever boris abgesendet er
schreibt aol wiese ist ja eigentlich auf
englisch mir geht's gut und dir mir auch
es voll krass wie schnell die eigentlich
mittlerweile antwortet ich wollte heute
mit dir über killer clowns sprechen
mache ich mal drei punkte dahinter damit
er weiß ist wirklich ein ernstes thema
das denn für ein spiel alles klar dicker
ich bin raus viele clowns ist kein spiel
sehr geehrter clever bot sondern
wirklich eine echt echt echt wo kriegt
man eigentlich dieses kind minister von
de gila clowns ist kein spiel clever bot
so ok und er antwortet yuan otto nikon
stewart illusion der neubau 47 ages
naturfilm was kunst war deutsche in mir
bitte lange kannst du deutsch sprechen
lieber clever bord ein understand what
you say deutsch clever deutsch ich
möchte auf deutsch mit ihr reden ein jo
jo 1 sascha tabaka wie starte die
website einfach mal weil ich weiß nicht
ob der mich wirklich nichts verstanden
hat ein paar sekunden später was ist
deine einstellung zu killer clowns über
clever bot neutral neutral coface ex
liverpooler klauen
willst du ein killer clown nee ich bin
ein mädchen alles klar als wenn mädchen
keine kippen bist ein mädchen und ein
killer clown nein ich bin ein mädchen
und heißt wer heißt marotta [ __ ] wer ist
murat verdiensten kacke hier moreira der
killer clown punkt punkt punkt okay
klamotten nein ich bin ein mädchen
namens club keinen sinn fonie so wyler
jude oder moreira was ist denn jetzt der
name aber ich bin ein junge warst du
jetzt ein junge oder ein mädchen ich bin
wie du ein kombi okay wir fangen von
vornherein ok haben wir ja schon eine
gute ausgangsbasis hast du bereits einen
killer clown gesehen es war dein
vorschlag dass wir zusammen
wahrscheinlich bin ich in der beziehung
mit dir sind wir in einer beziehung
lieber clever weil das wirklich echt
interessieren was der wenn du mit mir
rum machst wo mache ich denn mit dir
schreibt jetzt mal einfach zurück zum
thema und er schreibt okay du hast aber
vom thema abgelenkt okay das stimmt
natürlich auch so ein bisschen aber ich
schreibe jetzt einfach mal killer clown
in den städten jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt wie er darauf reagiert was soll
mir sowas sagen was soll mir das sagen
lieber clever bot dass ich fett bin
wahrscheinlich hast du mal julie frost
ist ein richtiger name lieber clever bot
fahrrad die mir her blöcke 22 alles klar
dk wenn man blöd 22 bei google eingibt
kriegt man zwei ergebnisse und das sind
hacker reporters was weißt du über
killer clowns clever bot dass sie mit
mir reden und schreiben
du hast kontakt zu den du hast also
kontakt zu den killer clowns über
klamotten nein du sollst deutsch
sprechen ich rede deutsch dubai ich rede
doch deutsch über clever bot bist du ein
mädchen oder ein junge ich bin ein
killer clown schreibe ich mal einfach
ist jetzt zwar geprüft jeder weiß dass
ich nicht bin aber mal schauen wie der
klare wort darauf reagiert er schreibt
nämlich und ich bin ein mädchen das
alleine in diesem video schon drei mal
dein geschlecht gewechselt magst du
killer clowns das würde mich echt mal
interessieren ja du nicht auch egal ob
du die magst ich habe gefragt ob du
killer clowns magst nein ich kenne dich
nicht persönlich alles klar der ja
wahrscheinlich persönlich hast du killer
clowns lieber klar wird gibt mir eine
antwort nein tut mir leid ich kenne dich
nicht locker bist du ein killer clowns
du ein
clever bot ich bin ein mediales das was
ihr vom video meine damen und herren ich
wollte einfach mal schauen was der
clever wort über killer clowns weiß wenn
euch das ganze gefahr dass auf jeden
fall mal like da würd mich mega freuen
und jetzt eine ganz kurze sache an die
technik leute und zwar habe ich hier so
ein asus laptop mit einer nvidia gtx
1080 die ich glaube ich relativ gut und
ich habe hier einen samsung monitor der
heiß samsung s 34 7 190 c um das ist so
ein 4k ultralight monitor und ich habe
diesen monitor auf der
bildschirmauflösung 3440 x 1440
eingestellt allerdings hat er dann ohne
aktualisierungsrate von 50 hertz das
heißt wenn ich jetzt meine maus bewege
ist das so leicht verzögert und das
stört mich halt enorm beim arbeiten
wisst ihr ob ich das irgendwie auf 60
hertz hochstellen kann weil die leiste
da geht nur bis 50 herz wenn ich 60
hertz haben will muss sich die auflösung
auf 2.560 x 1080 unterstellen dann sieht
das bild aber scheiße aus also ich hoffe
ihr versteht das ein bisschen was ich
meine
ich will einfach ein flüssiges bild
haben aber trotzdem bei der drei 1440 x
1440 auflösung also wenn ihr
technikfreak seid bitte schreibt
irgendwie kommentare wie es geht und an
die anderen zuschauer die davon keine
ahnung haben aber ihr seht jemanden der
sich da wirklich mit dieser thematik
auseinandergesetzt hat und vielleicht
eine lösung für mich hat dann wollte den
kommentar einfach mal hoch du dass ich
das sehen kann und dann vielleicht das
ganze hier noch besser das beste setup
besser aufbauen kann und ja sehen wir
uns in anderen video wieder